اجرى الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان اتصال
الهاتفيا مع نظيره الروسي بلادي ميرفتم
وقال بيان للرئاسه التركيه ان اردوغان
اعرب عن ابله بانهاء الحرب بين روسيا
واوكرانيا في اقرب وقت ممكن في اثناء قال
الاتحاد الاوروبي ان تعميقا علاقات
الاقتصاديه بين تركيا وروسيا يمثل مصدر
قلق كبير ويجب الا تساعد موستو على
الافلاج من العقوبه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات نبداها بالبحث في
دوافع المخاوف الاوروبيه من تقارب
الاقتصاديه تركيا
على لسان منسق السياسه الخارجيه للاتحاد
جوزيلا ثم ما هو الموقف الامريكي من تلك
المخاوي في الاوروبيه في الوقت الذي تلعب
فيه انقره دورا الوسيط بين واشنطن بشان
الصراع في اوكرانيا سياسيه ماء الاتصالات
السياسيه وقضيه تصدير الحبوب ثم نبحث كيف
ينعكس الدور التركي على مسار الازمه في
اوكرانيا وعلى علاقات انقره بحلفائها
الاقليميين والدوليين وما تاثيره على
المشهد في شمالي العراق وكذلك سوريا
[موسيقى]
اوروبا اذا تنظر بعين القلق للدور التركي
في سياق الحرب الدائره بين روسيا
واوكرانيا انقره التي تتحرك على اكثر من
خط يخشى الاتحاد الاوروبي من ان تفتح ثغره
في جدار العقوبات الغربيه المسلطه على
موسكو قلقون
كلما قرر وكثر الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان اتصالاته الهاتفيه مع اطراف
النزاع سواء لتامين الاتفاق حول مرور
الحبوب الاوكرانيه او للتخفيف من ازمه
الطاقه او الدعوه قبل وبعد كل ذلك لانهاء
الحرب برمتها اتصالات تتجاوز دائره حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا لتشمل الحدود الساخنه
بين تركيا وكذلك الشمال السوري وهنا كما
هناك تتقاطعوا اجندات ومصالح تجتهد انقره
لاداراتها على افضل وجه ممكن بيان عند
دائره الاتصال في الرئاسه التركيه قال ان
المباحثات
ده اردوغان وبوتين في اخر نسخه لها بحثت
مجددا ملف الطاقه كما تمت مناقشه القضايا
الاقليميه بما في ذلك ممر الحبوب ومكافحه
الارهاب ونقل بيان الرئاسه التركيه عن
الرئيس اردوغان انه ونظيره الروسي قد ضمن
وصول اكثر من 13 مليون طن من الحبوب الى
المحتاجين وانه يمكنهما البدء في العمل
على تصدير مختلف المنتجات الغذائيه والسلع
الاخرى تدريجيا في نطاق ممر الحبوب من
جانبه قال لكريم لان بوتين واردوغان تبادل
وجهات النظر بخصوص مبادره انشاء مركز
اقليمي لتصدير الغازي في تركيا واضاف
الكرملين لان قتل اكد لاردوغان ضروره
ازاله العوائق امام تصدير المنتجات
الزراعيه والاسمده الروسيه ضمن اتفاقيه
تصدير الحبوب
حراك تركيا على اكثر من صعيد وفي اكثر من
اتجاه دفع في ما يبدو منسق السياسه
الخارجيه للاتحاد جوزيف بوريل لتوجيه
رساله الى البرلمان الاوروبيه قال فيه ان
تعميق العلاقات الاقتصاديه بين تركيا
وروسيا يمثل مصدر قلق كبير وفق ما اوردته
مجموعته
الالمانيه واوضح بوريل وفق التقرير ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي وتركيا شركان في اتحاد
الجمركي يمنح حريه حركه البضائع التي تشمل
السلع ذات الاستخدام المزدوج وهي الصله
التي يمكن استخدامها لاغراض مدنيه وكذلك
عسكريه وشدد بريل على اهميه الا تساعد
تركيا روسيا في الافلاط من العقوبات
[موسيقى]
ليه مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من انقر
الدكتور بيلي جي اهان اوستوك المحلل
السياسي في مركز سيتا للابحاث ومن باريس
الدكتور ايمانويل رئيس معهد الاستشراف
والامن في اوروبا اهلا
دكتور ايمانويل من باريس عن محاوله فهم
هذا الموقف الاوروبي المعبر
ما سبب هذا الموقف الذي
يتجاوز الانزعاج الى التحذير
ماشي بغير العلاج
لا يفعله لانه يؤكد
ان يلعبوا على جبهه المختلفه قربه
السياسيه
مع روسيه وهو في الوقت نفسه
ميسر او مسهل او هكذا يقدم نفسه وهو معني
بطريقه التي
تقوم بها اوروبا
[موسيقى]
وهي تعمل الدخول الانضمام الى الاتحاد
مع السياسي الاوروبي
في الوقت نفسه ايضا اقتربت من الدول التي
تنتمي الى الفضاء
الروسي من خلال همم منظمه الدول
الناطقه بتركيا
وايضا مع سوريا ويمكن اضافه ليبيا اذا
القلق الاوروبي مبرر لان الرئيس التركي
همم
حول تصدير الحبوب
والذي مكن من اجتياز مضيقات
الرئيس التركي يلعب على الجبهتين
برغبته في عدم همم
المجتمع الدولي في العقوبات
والاستقلال هل هل افهم من كلامك دكتور
ايمانويل
هل افهم من كلامك ان هناك اتهاما اوروبيا
مباشره لانقره بانها
تقوم بالتحايل على العقوبات المفروضه على
روسيا
كيف يمكن ان تفسر
له هدف واحد
التمكين روسي
على العقوبات
النفط بستين دولار
للبرميل همم
يعكس ان همم
انابيب الغاز التي تمر تحت البحر الاسود
الاوروبيه
الرئيس اردوغان بمرحه هذه هذا البديل
للعقوبات هو يخدم مصلحته
الموقف المعبر عنه من قبل السيد بريل
يتجاوز الانزعاج الى الاتقام ويحمل لغه
تحذير لانقره
ببعض الامور ولكننا سبق واستمعنا الى هذه
الاتهامات في الماضي وهذه التحذيرات غير
المباشره من المسؤولين الاوروبيين وذلك
منذ بدايه الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا وذلك
لان الاتحاد الاوروبي والدول الاوروبيه لا
يمكنها
ان تعمل من خلال سياسه جيده مرتبطه
باوكرانيا راينا جوزيف وهو يحاول ان يقنع
رئيس بوتن قبل الحرب ورايين ايضا الرئيس
الفرنسي في جهوده لاقناعه بوتن وثنيه عن
الحرب ولكن هذه الجهود لم تؤتي اكلها حيث
ان الدول الاوروبيه لم تتمكن من لم تتمكن
من تحقيق الهدف المرجو وبالتالي الدول
الاوروبيه تواجه ازمه الطاقه وهي في ماء
الزهق لذلك تحاول ان تبحث عن جهه تتمها
بافشانه هذه السياسات الى حاولت اوروبا ان
تؤدي دور الوساطه
حاولت ان تصنع السلام
حاولت ان تسير على مساري السياسه مستقله
اذا ما عدنا على سبيل المثال في الى بدايه
الحرب فرنسا والمانيا لم تكونا لصالح
قراري فرض العقوبات على روسيا حاولتاه الا
تحد واحد والولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
هذا المجال وقاومتاه هذه العقوبات
التي كانت مطروحه لفتره طويله
ورايين ما حصل بعد ذلك من حيث التقدم
وصولا الى
فبالتالي الدول الاوروبيه
هل هل افهم من كلامك واعذرني على المقاطعه
ان همم ما يقوله الاتحاد او انقر لا تجد
نفسها معنيه بما يتعلق بالاثر ناظمه بين
الاتحاد الاوروبي وبين انقر بالاشاره الى
اتفاقيات الجمركيه عندما تتهم انقر بانها
لا تلت في العقوبات المفروضه اقتصاديا على
روسيا
فوديس تركي تركي هذا
لذلك حافظت تركيا على موقف مبدئيا في غايه
الوضوح قال تركيا انها لن تكون جزءا من
عقوبات احاديه تركيا تلتزم بالعقوبات التي
يفردها مجلس الامن التابعه للامم المتحده
وهذا واضح هذا هو الموقف التركي المبدئي
ما من ادنى شك بذلك لذلك لماذا سوف تعمل
تركيا ضد مصالحها من خلال اتباعه العقوبات
واحترام العقوبات الاحاديه لو احترمت
تركيا العقوبات الاحاديه ما كنا حضينا
بفرصه الحديث مع روسيا واوكرانيا في الوقت
نفسه
ولم نكن نتمكن من اجراء اتفاق لتبادل
السجناء بين الطرفين باضافه الى اتفاق
تصدير الحبوب قال لي شخصيا يسالون
اوكرانيون ان الامم المتحده نعم اثرت في
هذا المجال ولكن تركيا على وجه خصوص هي
الجهه التي امنت اتفاق الحبوب وانقذت
العالم من ازمه غذاء
الدكتور
فيما يتعلق بما قدم له بانه ازدواجيه في
الطاعات مع الدور التركي في الاقل ما يجي
الان محور موسكو وكذلك اكياف وانقره من
جهه يتم الاشاده بدور تركيا على سبيل
المثال مجرى في اتفاق الحبوب او هذه
الاشاده من قبل كياب لدور انقره او همم ما
تقوم به تركيا على صعيد العلاقه مع روسيا
في التوصل الى حل لما يجري في اوكرانيا
ومن الجهه ثانيه تنتقد وتنتقد ويتم تحذير
تركيا بهذه الصوره وهذا يجرني ايضا الى
سؤال اخر لو اذنت
هل الموقف الاوروبي يتطابق مع الموقف
الامري ما يتعلق بهذا التحذير الاوروبي
سؤالين مختلفين من الموقف التركي من
الاتفاق
الحبوب هو لا يتعلق فقط
بتركيا
اوروبا
تاتي من اوكرانيا ومن روسيا وتقطع همم
مضيقي البسفور وهرموس
اذن تركيا تقوم بدورها لانها هي التي تحمي
تنفيذ اتفاق وهي التي
تشرف على هذين المضيقين ثانيا تركيا
اقترحت خدماتها فيما يتعلق بالوساطه ولكن
ينبغي ان يتفق الطرفان الاوكراني والروسي
حول موضوع
وضعت همم لكن ما هي القاعده هل هي قاعده
ان منظمه التعاون الاوروبي سوف تضمن وعوده
الاراضي المحتله منذ 2014 الاراضي
الاوكرانيه ام هل
لمصلحه روسيا اي ان ننطلق من مبدا ان
تحتفظ بالاراضي التي ضمتها في الثلاثين من
سبتمبر الماضي همم
اقترحت او عرضت خدماتها وكان هناك لقاءات
في مستوى المستشارين
الدبلوماسيين ولكن ذلك لم يمضي ان لم يقطع
طريقا طويلا لان الامر الان غير واضح ولا
يشجع على المفاوضات لا على روسيا لا روسيا
ولا اوكرانيا ولكن من المهم ان تركيا
تقترح دورها
ببساطه لانها تكون ملتزمه من ناحيه لانها
عضو في حلف الناتو او روسيا قبل ان قبل
اسابيع كانت روسيا تؤكد ان حلف انيته هو
وترف في الحرب
ولكن بنظر الى الاجندات الامنيه المتعلقه
بانكر وموسكو بعض دكتور
دكتور
سالتك ماذا عن الموقف الامريكي
نعم نعم
سؤالي فيما يتعلق بالموقف الامريكي ان كان
يتطابق مع الموقف الذي عبر عنه السيد
جوزيل فيما يتعلق بهذا الانزعاج وهذه
الاتهامات وهذا التحذير الموجه لتركيا في
علاقاتها خاصه الاقتصاديه مع روسيا
موقع المتحده ليست مشكلتها
سوف تفاوض مع روسيا لموضوع لا يهم فقط
اوكرانيا
تتفاوت حول الطرق التي ينبغي ان يتفق بها
الدوله على النواحي النوويه وتبادل
السجناء وراينا ذلك وانما حدث طيب
الامارات حول
صائد ما تفسيرك لهذا الموقف الاوروبي
نحن نتحدث عن جهد من الاتحاد الاوروبي
للقاء اللومي على طرف معين في هذه الازمه
ان اوروبا تتعرض للضغط من قبل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وهي تحاول ان تبحث عن
كبش فداء ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
فرضت العقوبات على روسيا
ونعوذ بالذاكره الى مقاومه المانيا لهذا
الامر بالنسبه الى شراء
همم نفط الروسيه وتطلب الامر ضخطا من جانب
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لتاهيل الموقف
الالماني وايضا فرنسا حاولت ان لا تستطيع
رؤوس روسيا ولقد اجتمعنا ايضا الى
الاوكرانيين وقد تحدث عن النصائح الاوربيه
التي وجهها الاوروبيون
وكانت تقضي بقبول اوكرانيا بان تضم روسيا
بعض الاراضي وذلك للتوسل الى حل دائم
وبالتالي الصوره واضحه الاوروبيون يعانون
من ازمه طاقه ويريدون كبش الفداء ان تركيا
لا تعاني بنفس الدرجه
واوروبا تقول لتركيا لماذا لا تعانين
لماذا لا تشاركينا في هذه العقبات ويقولون
لتركيا انها تخرق هذه
العقوبات ولا تحترم على عقبات ولكن تركيا
تقول ان الموقف الذي اتخذته واضح ونعود
الى اتفاقيه مونتريال بالنسبه الى المرور
عبر المضيقي
الى بعض الامور الاخرى وهي تؤمن اصلا
الاسلحه الى الاوكراني طيب ال ال ال
القضايا كثيره سيد اوستورك همم وهنا سؤالي
اللي ضيفي من فارس الدكتور دبوي ايضا جزء
من الانزعاج المعبر عنهم من قبل السيد
بوري لان هناك اتصالات كثيره بين الرئيسين
اردوغان
وبوتين وهذا امر غريب
الطرفان تحدث على ان جزء من هذه الاتصالات
تعلق بما يجري ربما ما تنوي تركيا فعله او
القيام به من عمليات بريه في الشمال
السوري
في الشمال السوري وبالتالي الى اي مدى قد
يؤثر هذا الموقف الاوروبي على ملفات اخرى
كالذي يجري او تنوي تركيا فعله في الشمال
السوري
يوتيوب
ليست هذه مفاجاه
2015 هناك عمليه
الدبلوماسيه الايرانيه والتركيه
ومرتبطه جنيف حول حل الازمه في سوريا ايام
نعرف ان الناطق باسم الكريم
بعضهم بعضا
ان ابراهيم كان يتحدث الروسيه يتحدث
التركيه اذا هناك همم تقارب
الجانبين وينبغي ان نتذكر ايضا ان تركيا
تتحدث الى الجميع
وهذه هذه افضل طريقه لوصفها وهي دبلوماسيه
360 درجه
شكرا لك للاسف واعتذر من الضيفين لقد
ادركنا الوقت ضيف من باريس الدكتور
ايمانويل رئيس معهد الاستشراف والامن في
اوروبا وكذلك لضيف من انقر الدكتور
المحلل السياسي في مركز سيتا
كتاب هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر
اللقاء
[موسيقى]